côté de vous et hervé guibert écrivain
et journaliste dose livre le 13e
s'intitule à l'ami qui ne m'a pas sauvé
la vie chez gallimard
vous avez écrit beaucoup de livres
impudique et risqué celui ci est le plus
risqué le plus impudique qui a vous y
parlez de la maladie qui altère votre
corps et qui modifie votre conscience
le sida est ce que vous vous rappelez la
première fois vous avez entendu parler
de cette maladie bizarre qu'il n'avait
encore pas de noms qui attaquaient des
homosexuels
quelle a été votre réaction bah c'est un
ami qui travaille dans le milieu médical
qui avait qui avait lu 7 7
cette petite rubrique d'atlanta qui qui
m'a dit à quelque chose d'incroyable
apparemment en train de se passer et je
lui raconte dans le livre d'ailleurs
enfin quand je les j'en ai tout de suite
je crois que le soir même je dînais avec
michel foucault qui j'ai dit et qui
s'est tordu de rire quoi qui s'est dit
que ça il a failli 6 est tombé par terre
de rire il a dit écoute qu'est ce que
c'est que cette cette affabulation c'est
trop il m'a dit écoute un concert de no
sexuel ce serait trop beau pour être
vrai quoi oui ça me paraissait un peu se
bat moelle oui je sais pas si ça me
semblait un peu un peu saugrenue comme
en écrivant ce livre à l'ami qui ne m'a
pas sauvé la vie à quelles exigences à
quelle nécessité vous obéit si on est
dans ce livre sur le sida en général sur
votre sida en particulier
je crois que
déjà pendant des années j'ai voulu tenir
ce mot sida le plus loin de moi possible
donc ça existait comme beaucoup de gens
quelques fois je me disais c'est sûr
mais aussi jeux de l'avoir à d'autres
moments je me disais non c'est pas
possible je les ai pas et en tout cas de
jus donc j'ai continué à écrire et j'ai
jamais voulu écrire ce mot quoi pas si
par superstition
bon il ya eu délit délivre régulièrement
qui sont sortis sur le sida des romans
des livres enquêtes
je voulais absolument rien lire de ça et
pendant ce temps là en même temps je je
il y avait dans ma vie plein de sève et
pas seulement des appréhensions mais
attention il y avait des avait des
prémonitions comme ça très curieuse il y
avait aussi des conjurations au fait
contre ces éléments de prémonition et
des tentatives d'exorcisme et des voeux
tout ça il y avait aussi des gens
atteints du sida autour de vous il y
avait aussi dont il était j'ai été
témoin donc de la mort de michel
foucault fait ça alors sous on le
reconnaît y vous l'appelez musique dans
votre votre lit mais évidemment tous ont
reconnu tout de suite michel foucault et
qui était votre ami mais évidemment que
vous avez de la presse on a beaucoup
parlé et c'est dans les journaux on
s'est posé cette question est ce que
vous aviez le droit de raconter l'agonie
et la mort de michel foucault qui était
votre ami je crois que je ne sais pas si
j'avais le droit ou pas je crois que
de toute façon cette mort cette agonie
n'appartient à personne ne m'appartient
pas je suis pas le détenteur de la
vérité sur cette mort là simplement j'ai
pu remarquer que donne dans dance qui
m'étaient reprochés
non seulement quand même une grande
malhonnêteté parce que cet hebdomadaire
à sensation qui m'a fait le plus grand
procès puisqu'il a développé ce procès
sur huit pages en faisant un sondage
auprès d'auteurs qui n'avaient pas lu le
livre pour le demander pour leur monter
le bourrichon en disant il ya ça yassa
et dans le livre tous ah bon il se
trouve que cet hebdomadaire m'avait
s'était jetée vraiment sur les épreuves
en disant formidable on publie ont fait
le scoop on publie ont fait la vérité
sur la mort de michel foucault bon j'ai
refusé à partir de là ils ont retourné
ils ont retourné le système en donnant
en faisant des leçons de morale et tout
ça mais bon moi bon je trouve aussi
qu'il ya derrière tout ça c'est ce qui
m'énerve le plus d'ailleurs une bon une
hypocrisie une pudibonderie quand même
parce que tout le côté bon la vie privée
le respect de la vie privée tout ça bon
michel foucault c'était quelqu'un qui
était évidemment attentifs à la notion
de vie privée
mais c'était aussi quelqu'un qui était
qui a vu une liberté dans sa vie qui a
vu une audace est bon ils étaient tous
ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
homosexuels closeau de queen c'est à
dire une tente de plaka enfin c'était
quelqu'un qui vont qui sortait très
rarement mais quand il sortit avec
quelques amis quand il allait au cinéma
bon il aimait il aimait embrasser ses
amis
c'est quelqu'un aussi en marre projet de
choses sur le sur le solde au masochisme
et c'est bon ils aillent il a donné des
interviews sur le sadomasochisme il n'a
pas donné au monde au journal le monde
il a expliqué que pour lui c'était une
école de la délicatesse de l'attention à
l'autre que c'était tout sauf quelque
chose qui est relevé la brutalité enfin
bon je sais pas c'était quelqu'un aussi
bon cheval de son blouson de cuir pour
sortir le samedi soir mais aussi bon le
dimanche matin pour aller faire son
marché d'un seul coup sans doute il se
disait bon moment taux chinois à col de
fourrure était trop lourd finalement
c'est commode ce blouson c'est léger bon
j'ai rencontré un matin puisque on était
voisins dans une pâtisserie avec son
blouson bon ça faisait un drôle d'effet
mais mme hervé guibert quand vous avez
assisté à l'agonie de michel foucault
est ce que vous saviez vous que vous
aviez getti porte ce que je raconte dans
le livre c'est à dire bon jeu correspond
à l'incubation bon bizarrement même le
temps l'amitié puisque je les ai connus
en 1977 il est mort en 1984 ce temps de
cette amitié qui a eu une croissance
très très bizarre très lente et je m'en
rends compte maintenant a correspondu au
temps d'incubation de la maladie plus ou
moins puisque approximativement bon les
gens disent des gens disent que le temps
d'incubation est de 4 à 8 en moyenne au
disque
il n'est pas vraiment fixé de 10 ce qui
fait dix ans que tout ça bon j'allais le
voir à l'hôpital et
mais bon je me suis mis très vite à
écrire chaque fois que je rentrais de
l'hôpital bon c'était des choses
intolérables je me suis mise
je me suis mis à les écrire dans mon
journal je crois que je les fais en fait
pour oublier ces choses parce que le
quand j'écris tout ce que j'ai écrit une
fois que c'est écrit c'est oublier donc
ça me permettait d'oublier
instantanément les choses au fur et à
mesure et en même temps bon on est
arrivé à un moment je me suis dit mais
de quel droit je fais ça qu est-ce qu il
serait furieux quoi je me disais ils
seraient ils seraient ils seraient peiné
il serait je fais un acte de traîtrise
là en faisant ça même si je le fais pour
l'oublier et d'un seul coup ça a été
vraiment commune comme une révélation
comme quelque chose comme une vision
quoi quelque chose de très très curieuse
je me suis dit en fait je suis habilité
complètement écrire ça parce qu'en fait
c'est mon propre destin et c'est ma
propre mort que je sais en train de
raconter la mort de foucault vous
racontez votre propre meurt ça non
c'était dans le journal c'est au moment
où je en même temps je me suis pas chaud
servi de mon journal parce que je ne
pouvais pas je suis même pas retourner
pour écrire mon livre parce que c'était
trop serré les matières trop intolérable
mais c'est vrai que vous êtes très
impudique et en même temps vous ne vous
ménagez pas vous même ce que vous dites
par exemple la lendemain j'étais seule
dans la chambre avec musique musique
zouk ou je pris longuement sa main comme
il mettait parfois arrivé de le faire
dans son appartement puis j'applique et
mes lèvres sur la main pour le baiser en
rentrant chez moi je savonnet célèbre
avait compté soulagement comme si elles
avaient été contaminées
j'étais tellement heureux soulagé c'est
terry d'écrire ça oui c'est terrible
c'est la vérité je raconte aussi que
après
un baiser il ya un épisode à mexico vous
avez là vraiment converser par ce nom
c'est vrai nom mais je veux dire qu'il
faut dix films pour raconter ça c'est
vrai parce que j'aime et je ne sais pas
en même temps pour moi la vérité a une
vertu renvoyé aussi c'est pour cela
terrible et triste et cruelle soit elle
je ne sais pas aussi il ya aussi des
effets de délicatesse dans là il ya
quelque chose de une certaine
délicatesse de trouver dans ce baiser
sur cette main est aussi dans ma peur
est dans le fait de l'avouer quoi j -c
soir alors l'ami qui ne m'a pas sauvé la
vie c'est la deuxième partie du livre
c'est un américain qui était un ami à
vous et qui est donc un homme d'affaires
et qui est un laboratoire et qui vous
promet un vaccin qui vous promet un
médicament pour vous guérir et dès que
vous savez ça ça change votre vie d'une
certaine manière et en même temps c'est
un imposteur
c'est le début du livre c'est la
première phase et j'ai eu le sida
pendant trois mois ce qui ce qui a fait
que quand j'ai vu ma grand tante louise
dimanche dernier elle médias c'est
formidable north est guéri s'écrit dans
le figaro cette semaine parce que dans
la page télé ils ont pris la première
phrase utilisée il ya vu jules sida
pendant trois mois et c'est quelqu'un
qui ne pas être en contact avec les
actualités ni avec la rubrique médical
donc j'ai dit c'est jusqu'à nouvel ordre
malheureusement le sida est encore une
maladie incurable et bon non c'est vrai
que ça m'a ça va ça me parce que bon
quand on a des prémonitions on a des
choses comme ça on a des yeux doux il ya
une alternance dans la conscience à
certains moments on a besoin et avant
qu'on le sache vraiment et après qu'on
le sache bon c'est pas les mêmes à
l'alternance de conscience mais bon une
fois savoir qu'on est séropositif bon
c'est quand même pour l'instant jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant c'est quelque chose
d'implacable c'est quand même
quand je raconte bon quand je suis allé
faire le tese raconte le regard
absolument éperdue d'un jeune homme qui
sortait et une semaine avant que moi
j'ai ce résultat je me suis vu dans une
semaine quoi et c'est vrai que le moins
de s'écroule c'est tout change quoi
partir de ça et bompas c'est vrai que
pendant trois mois puisque c'était une
malade puisque c'est une maladie jusqu'à
nouvel ordre incurable bon c'est une
expérience incroyable et donc oui
pendant trois mois j'ai recalculé ce
temps après je ne sais pas si c'est
exactement trois mois ou tantes jour 57
jours où je sais pas j'ai commencé à
accomplir quelque chose selon moi même
qui m'a amené dans la conscience que la
force des choses je me rapprochais
beaucoup de la mort que est bon c'est
aussi une expérience une expérience
difficile mais c'est aussi une
expérience dont je le dis dans le livre
de même que le que le sida attaque le
corps qui le quiller qui ratatine qui la
grèce qu'ils ont mais il a aussi un
effet sur la conscience forcément il a
un effet de dans le meilleur des cas de
d'épanouissement en face et un bond en
avant il ya une j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya une progression de la conscience
comme ça et d'un seul coup pas par par
le hasard incroyable qui m'a fait être
en contact avec cet ami qui ce qui se
disait détenteur avec des possibilités
qu'ils pouvaient l'ignorer que j'étais
malade quand quand il a dit ça mais de
quelque chose qui pourrait me sauver ça
va finalement ça va presque plus trg
versez que d'apprendre que quand j'avais
appris que j'avais que j'avais six
d'accueil mais c'est un imposteur et
c'est terrible quand même le mal qu'il
vous fait et un certain moment
d'ailleurs il ya une scène terrible
terrible où ils quittent le restaurant
et vous pourriez simplement faire couler
une goutte de sang dans son verre de vin
oui parce que c'est un ami majorité oui
mais parce qu'en même temps je l'aimais
enfin je n'arrive pas à me départir de
l'affection que mme halimi la tuer
symboliquement et le livre et le livre
de lui rend bien puisque c'est à l'abri
jouer aussi le livre est mon instrument
pour le tuer quoi c'est un crime et mais
bon moi il me fascine en tant que
personnage jamais eu un personnage comme
ça j'aurais jamais pu l'inventer il ya
des gens il est trop beau pour être vrai
il ya des gens d'aller d'ailleurs qui
pensent que que c'est un dérapage dans
la fiction un moment du livre puisque
dans certains livres
je m'étais amusé à sur une base un peu
documentaire comme par exemple des
aveugles à établir quelque chose de vrai
pour pouvoir inventer une fiction mais
c'est cet ami un ami américain qui
s'appelle bill qui vous dit à un moment
et c'était règle aussi de toute façon tu
n'aurais pas supporté vie en faisant
c'est assez formidable
c'est ça c'est sa propre peur aussi et
de la maladie du vieillissement et tout
ça pour ce qui est de la goutte de vin
donc de la goutte de sang dans le vin
parce que c'est assez amusant c'était
donc un ami proche qui était révolté
parce que c'est pas un ami écrivain et
c'est un ami qui voit la réalité qu'ils
voient pas qu'ils n'arrivent pas à voir
un personnage comme jeudi en or massif
dans le livre et qui m'a dit comment tu
peux dîner avec sept ans x ray kiki te
trahir quoi tu devrais vraiment je t'en
supplie je t'en supplie prend une
aiguille et dès qu'il ira aux toilettes
ou qui tourna le dos vers son supplice
et il ya la correctrice des éditions
gallimard qui est qu'une dame adorable
qu'une cinquantaine d'années qui a dit
vous savez monsieur gilbert moi je suis
peut-être méchante mais si j'étais
l'héroïne de votre livre voilà goutte de
sang je l'aurais laissé tomber dans le
vert
vous avez acheté de la digitaline vue
d'un suicide par un réveil coeur vous
l'avez toujours digital je me suis
beaucoup renseigné
ça fait dix ans que je me renseigne sur
la façon dont ça quelqu'un soit qui m'a
dit mettez trop belle pourquoi t'as pas
acheter le livre que tout le monde
achète soit bon je me suis renseigné
auprès d'un médecin
j'ai vérifié dans le vidal de mes grand
temps de latence vous avez l'intention
pas vous c'est maintenant à cause du
livre par murray dans tout a changé et
que c'est par moment je me suis
rapproché de l'idée du suicide plus que
jamais après avoir fait le livre un
moment ce que bon le livre continue j'y
aille
il ya une mise en place de c'est pour ça
que c'est pour moi c'est aussi un roman
ce livre comme on pour moi tout est vrai
dans ce livre parce que rien ne pouvait
être faux dans ce livre là donc
mais en même temps je trouve que c'est
un roman parce qu'il ya une construction
et un suspense qui est mis en place dès
la première page et qui me laisse
jusqu'au bout mais temps c'est un livre
qui est agressif qui est noir avec même
de l'humour noir et donc ils ressemblent
même au sida une certaine manière il
assis là cette violence il a cette
agressivité et est-ce que vous avez vous
lu il ya souvent des phrases très très
longue
c'est pourquoi c'est comme des poussées
de fièvre des emportements il ya aussi
l'aspect
j'ai dit que j'ai écrit ce livre dans la
découverte qui a été complètement
sidérante pour moi de l'écrivain
autrichien thomas bernhard
oui que depuis dix ans des amis me
disaient il faut absolument que tu lis
thomass bernard tu sais pas envie
d'aller en plus c'est vraiment un
écrivain pour toi et tout ça bon comme
canton de convaincre quelqu'un dont je
les ai découverts au moment où
j'écrivais ce livre est souvent dans des
livres que j'ai fait il ya un écrivain
derrière qui est comme humain comme un
fantôme comme une ombre projetée sur sur
le texte et de même que là j'ai mon
travail était devenu le sida les le le
sydam travailler et je me suis laissé
travailler par moments par cette
colonisation comme ça c'était comme un
fagot ctge de ma propre écriture avec
des avec des aussi des moments où je me
défends des si des gens mais disons mère
teresa français disent on prie pour vous
est-ce que signification pour vous
est-ce que c'est un réconfort est ce que
moi je suis pas croyant mais je suis
superstitieux jeu j'adore les veuves
j'adore moindre éclipse de lune bon
c'est un peu rare mais moins de
champagne aux premières fraises aux
premières asperges toujours et depuis
deux trois ans toujours le veut c'est la
survie pour socgen pour les malades du
sida vous est dédié à cette bonne heure
heure quotidienne à la première fraises
les premiers seles non ce oui enfin
c'est un peu rituel quoi se toucher du
bois
tout ça est ce que vous allez écrire un
autre livre j'écris plus quand je vois
pas de bah je sais pas sa masse quand
j'ai appris donc la nouvelle ça m'a
complètement galbe galvanisé j'écris
beaucoup j'ai écrit en fait
livre qui est sorti avant j'écris un
livre de 400 pages que j'ai condamné qui
sortira donc pas est bon là j'écris plus
parce que je après ce livre là enfin je
vois pas ce que je pourrais écrire quoi
déjà j'écrirai pas d'autres livres sur
le sida est bon c'est un peu triste mais
c'est comme ça merci
[Musique]